ich würde einfach mal schätzen 174 weil
sie sich schon recht groß aus und sie
ist 150 was geht ab und jetzt willkommen
bei einem neuen video oder oben auch
einmal konnten wir gerade solche
rausgekramt wir haben schon wieder sonne
hitze hier in köln es sind glaube ich 30
grad gestern hatten wir 32 grad und ich
mache trotzdem jeden tag hier mein video
also wenn das jetzt keine daumen nach
oben verdient hat dann weiß ich auch
nicht jetzt wahrscheinlich habt ihr
schon gelesen heute mal wieder mit einem
thema das ist sehr sehr lange nicht
gehabt aber das habe ich vor ungefähr
einem jahr so ich sag mal so nach
deutschland geholt oder hat youtube
deutschland und zwar geht es um gäste
das gab es damals in amerika gäste und
ich habe es dann in deutschland ich
erwarte euer alter extrem schwer
genannter so schreibt gerne in die
kommentare ob ich das video gesehen habt
es geht aber nicht um alte rad oder
sonst was ich habe mir eigentlich was
überlegt was ist so noch gar nicht gab
obwohl das hat bestimmt schon irgendwer
gemacht ich erwarte größe ein paar leute
haben das schon gemacht ich erwarte ich
schätze eure größe wie stellen wir das
nämlich wirklich interessant vor allem
weil man ja oft leute auf fotos sieht
denkt dann bot er ist aber groß und dann
sieht man die im real life und denkt
sich alter ist ja klar so wurde ich zum
beispiel schon auf der straße
angesprochen von leuten die meisten
profis zu groß und leute die meinen
handys zufolge also ihr habt wirklich
sehr sehr viele fotos von euch geschickt
ich will gar nicht lange lagern für noch
ein paar klasse auf jeden fall mal 7000
likes da und wir fangen an mit dem
ersten foto und das ist okay das erste
foto ist nur zuschauerin muss man erst
mal sagen sehr idyllische umgebung
schöne bäume im hintergrund auch gerade
das mit der wiese und ja diesem
gestrippt gefällt mir richtig gut auch
gar nicht im kontrast zum t-shirt das t
shirt spiegelt ungefähr die gleiche
farbe wieder
ich würde sagen die person ist noch
etwas jünger deswegen schätze ich jetzt
einfach mal 1 meter 60 wir können ja
sagen solange ich entweder 3 cm drüber
oder drunter läge es voll okay also wenn
sie jetzt zum beispiel 157 ist und ich
hab gesagt ein 60 griechen punkt und
wenn sie 163 es kriegt auch noch ein
punkt und wir schauen jetzt einfach
mal rein sie ist 172 gutes war ja voll
daneben hätte ich jetzt wirklich nicht
gedacht
ja sie sieht für mich auf jeden fall
noch ein bisschen jünger aus deswegen
wirkt das auch irgendwie kleiner also
ich hätte jetzt sogar gedacht 160 mio
vielleicht ist das sogar ein bisschen zu
groß weil ich sagen würde die person ist
auf jeden fall noch ein bisschen yoga
aber gut
schöne grüße gehen raus an wen haben wir
denn hier celina so willkommen zum
nächsten foto und haben hier wieder ein
mädchen das kommen gleich aber auch noch
ein jungs ich habe heute längst darauf
geachtet dass nicht nur mädchen im video
sind sehr hübsches foto jetzt ist
natürlich die frage zielt sie ihren
absatz hat zu oder nicht das outfit
zieht auf jeden fall ziemlich feierlich
aus wahrscheinlich geht es durch auf
einer hochzeit oder so ich würde einfach
mal sagen diese person ist ein meter 68
also ein meter 71 ist okay 1 meter 75
ist auch noch ok alles was dazwischen
das auch und wir schauen mal rein
172 nein das war eng
wiso-tipp ich eigentlich die ganze zeit
zu klein nur weil ich so klein und
obwohl so klein bin ich auch nicht und
sie schickt hier noch so ein baby smiley
mit 172 ist für mädchen ja gar nicht mal
klein es ist eigentlich echt groß gut
willkommen zum nächsten foto okay die
person ist jetzt aber wirklich junger
guckt irgendwie ganz schön grimmig das
nächste mal auf jeden fall lachen aber
auch hier gefällt mir das outfit sehr
ich muss ja auch irgendwie immer was zum
foto sagen sonst ist ja langweilig eine
ganz wichtig schätzt auf jeden fall auch
immer in den kommentaren mit was würdet
ihr sagen jetzt bei dieser person
schreibt in die kommentare
123 45 sekunden ich sage ein meter 3 und
wieder zu klein ein meter 53 und sie ist
ich würde jetzt sagen sie ist maximal 13
mit 13 war ich vielleicht 1 58 oder soja
ich war sehr klein so nicht einen punkt
habe ich gesammelt das läuft wie am
schnürchen
jetzt muss ich aber okay wir kommen als
nächstes hierzu der erste junge wie zur
bist du auf jeden fall da das ist jetzt
wirklich echt schwer ich würde den
einfach mal ungefähr so groß schätzen
wie mich deswegen sage ich ein teenie
com
ich war immer falsch deswegen sag jetzt
einfach mal erst ein meter 84 was würdet
ihr sagen schreib es auf jeden fall in
die kommentare
und wir haben ein meter 86 okay das
heißt ein punkt für mich ein meter 780
wir auch noch okay gewesen also finde an
dieser stelle schöne grüße ich finde 186
ist für jungs echt ne coole größe ich
wäre gerne ein kleines bisschen größer
aber ich bin in meiner größe eigentlich
mittlerweile auch zufrieden ja kommen
wir zum nächsten bild und das ist gilt
das ist dieses hier hier kann man das
wirklich sehr sehr schwer einschätzen
wir haben diesen kamerawinkel so leicht
von oben drauf habe ich schon sehr
vieles erlebt sie könnte 150 sein
sie könnte aber auch 180 sein das ist
wirklich schwer zu sagen ich würde jetzt
einfach mal blind schätzen vielleicht so
ein mittel war's ich sag jetzt einfach
mal vom alter würde ich sie so auf 18
schätzen deswegen müssten sie schon
ausgewachsen sein oder ihren schutz
schon gemacht haben und deswegen würde
ich sagen 1 meter 70 okay ich bin
gespannt ein punkt habe ich gesammelt
und sie ist 179 es war aber wieder voll
daneben das ist wirklich so schwer zu
sagen einfach weil das also 179 für
mädchen ist ja schon groß da bist du
eigentlich so groß wie ich ich bin
vielleicht ein zentimeter ja wenn ich
schon habt ihr nicht größer aber wenn du
hunger hast bist du größer auch an
dieser stelle schöne grüße an dich ganz
wichtig leute schickt mir auch alle
fotos von euch zu binden mal ins video
wollt dann kann ich mal schauen ob ich
eure größe richtig erraten kann
wir lassen uns gar nicht lange aufhalten
und machen weiter mit diesem bild das
ist jetzt wirklich schwer zu sagen vor
allem weil ich eigentlich immer auch so
ein bisschen aufs alter achtung dann zu
schließen zu können weil man kann das ja
dann immer so ein bisschen mehr
eingrenzen ob die person ist allerdings
dass zwölf ist oder schon 16 kann ich
nicht sagen
deswegen will wie hier auch einfach mal
die mitte ich würde sagen 14 und stufe
sie auf 162 okay leute 321 und sie ist
156 arnheim in sanaa wieder schöne grüße
an dich ich habe mich ein bisschen
größer eingeschätzt
aber jetzt habe ich glaube ich aus sechs
kandidaten zwei punkte gesammelt
und das ist auf jeden fall noch luft
nach oben haben wir zum nächsten foto
und das nächste bild ist von o
warum hat diese langeweile also die
entweder sie hat die hose ziemlich weit
hochgezogen oder das ist von unten das
spiel glaube ich alles so ein bisschen
zusammen ich würde einmal schätzen zwei
meter 20 viel spaß
was würdet ihr sagen schreib es in die
kommentare trainer rudi das outfit
gefällt mir eigentlich ganz gut aber
darum geht es ja gar nicht bei euch ich
würde eigentlich mal schätzen 174 weil
sie sieht schon recht groß aus zwar eher
dünn aber echt groß könnte aber auch
kleiner sein weil es halt am winkel
liegt und das bild dann diese
proportionen total falsch wiedergeben
sie es 150 was das war ja war voll
nehmen was habe ich gesagt 174 also 24
zentimeter unterschied alte alex ihr
hättet ihr gedacht dass sie 150 ist das
ist ja die kleinsten vom ganzen video
ich hätte echt gedacht das wäre
eigentlich die größte ihr könnt auch
gern mal in die kommentare schreiben
ob ich vielleicht noch mal ich weiß ich
hab das ja vor einem jahr angefangen
weil ab und zu kriege ich halt mal so
nachrichten ja alex von aids immer
wieder alter und so was also schreibt
gerne in die kommentare ob ihr darauf
lust habt vielleicht auch irgendwas
anderes von euch erwarten weil es echt
immer unterhaltsam ist und dann schaue
ich mir die kommentare mal an dass ich
mich das ein bisschen an euch orientiere
und dann einfach mal weiter drauflos rat
auf install um heißt alex wieder könnt
ihr mir die ganzen fotos schicken ein
paar leute haben wir noch ich bin
gespannt und wir machen einfach mal
weiter haben hier den erwarte hier einen
etwas jüngeren jungen er 50 hose
doch eher 50 m ist mir jetzt nicht böse
aber ich würde dich echt jung
einschätzen deswegen sage ich jetzt
einmal 19 und 151 und wir haben 14 was
habe ich das passt genau um 3 cm wir
haben eben gesagt das ist okay drei
punkte für mich das ist der louis 13
jahre alt grüße hier raus amtlich ich
glaube jetzt in den nächsten jahren kann
sich freuen da machst einen richtigen
schub nach oben war bei mir auch so und
ja machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten
foto und das ist das hier das outfit
gefällt mir auch sehr gut
natürlich muss man diesen wird zeigen
wie man jedoch trägt wohl selbst schon
das outfit an dieser stelle habe ich ja
schon gesagt ich würde sie einfach
weil sie nicht auf 18 schätzen oder
vielleicht 17 jahre 17 18
und sie ist 1 meter 1 meter 68 sie hat
sogar noch ein zweites bild mitgeschickt
einmal dieses coole latschen
ich bleibe meinen anbieter 68 und wir
schauen rein es sind 1 meter 70 okay gut
ich sage jetzt glaube ich vier oder fünf
mal falsch vier mal auch richtig das
heißt eine person bleibt uns noch übrig
wir können jetzt ich finde so schlecht
stelle ich mich gar nicht an und wir
haben noch mal einen jungen der sich
gross aus also hier würde ich jetzt
wirklich mal sagen irgendwas zwischen
182 und 190 ja eigentlich würde ich mich
da schon so an 190 orientieren wobei ich
sag jetzt einfach mal 186 pass auf dass
du nicht durch die brennessel läuft sie
da kurz vor die sind ja heute was würdet
ihr sagen schreibe es in die kommentare
ganz schnell
ich sag 186 und er ist 170 und 20 jahre
alt ich hätte ich jetzt viel größer
eingeschätzt irgendwie siehst du auf dem
foto niebels groß aus
na ja schon wieder falsch das ist
wirklich schwieriger als man dann viel
viel schwieriger ich würde ja genau
jetzt wenn ich mein video fertig habt
zieht es nicht zu draußen also ich glaub
es sogleich gewinnt hat aber ist auch
mal schön so ein bisschen regen genießt
das schöne wetter wenn ihr schönes
wetter hat bei euch ich würde sagen wir
sehen uns eventuell morgen wieder schaut
euch auf jeden fall das video an was
gestern kam und das von vorgestern auch
lohnt sich und ja ich wünsche euch noch
einen schönen tag haut rein